Film Courage: How often are you looking for
scripts to purchase?
Jay Silverman, producer/director/photographer:
Constantly.
Film Courage: What is the process?
Where are you looking?
Jay: I’m looking right now for a script
for my next movie and working on ideas at
the same time.
We’ve had some bumps in the road.
I tried to option a book, got very excited
about it and it turns out the book was entangled
in another country even though the rights
had run out, the other country had a tax credit
for the film and gave them advance funds which
I didn’t know this but it legally terminates
any kind of future purchase because the money
is already at play, I never knew that.
Film Courage: It’s fascinating information
because I would never think that either.
These are all things that…
Jay: I don’t think the writer of the book
knew that either.
Film Courage: Wow.
So once you found out that this is probably
a no-go…
Jay: This was just a week ago…
Film Courage: It was a week ago?
Okay…how do you kind of get back on the
horse and start looking for something?
Jay: I started immediately.
I mean a filmmaker doesn’t typically have
just one project that he’s interested in
doing.
In my case I have a pretty important mandate.
I’m only looking to do projects that are
personally beneficial to the world.
And I’m not talking about pollution or something
like that.
I’m talking about a meaningful project that
would help people engage and see things.
Filmmaking is so brilliant.
I just saw a great movie I can mention it
called THE INSULT and it’s a masterpiece!
Why is it a masterpiece?
Go see the movie and you’ll understand because
it talks about…it didn’t matter that it
was filmed in Lebanon.
What mattered to me was it could have been
anywhere.
And whether you are talking positive about
politics or negative, it could have happened
anywhere.
And it was not a true story, it was fiction.
But the way it was filmed and the way it was
written really tells a great story about tolerance
and talks about hatred.
And when you see a film like that and you
walk out, you are affected in a way almost
Shakespearean.
And that’s the kind of films that I want
to make.
Films that viscerally help you understand
the world more and maybe make you more tolerant,
maybe make you more perceptive and certainly
filmmaking is one of the best vehicles other
than speech or a book.
And to me a filmmaker really has an opportunity
to tell a story with the belief (not in a
purposeful preaching) but the belief is you’ll
walk out and you’ll have a perspective you
might never have had.